tsm weren't supposed to win the 2022-6
invitational tsm
early exit no roster moves since the
middle of last year so achieved bolo
chala geo and merc you'd think would
have had enough time to perfect their
formula by now tsm they've definitely
had a rough year for sure there's a lot
of pressure on tsm they had to play
qualifiers to even make it their roster
was stale but most importantly they lost
when it mattered most time and time
again refi finally getting some action
in geo he's been cut off if he goes down
that's it space station gaming takes
control of the series tsm had the
potential to be gods on paper they were
one of the best siege teams in the world
since the moment they formed and yet at
siege's world championship they kept
falling short and surely this is missing
the direction of liquid bolos through
the smoke parlor who has no idea when
they come through it's nesca and sexy
cake i'm sure you can hear team liquid
in the background they win tsm came into
si 2022 ready to prove they had what it
took but to the doubters they were still
the same team that just couldn't win if
it wasn't for the qualifiers tsm
wouldn't be in the grand final right now
but where others saw stagnation tsm saw
a roster that spent a year and a half
learning how to play together where
others saw a team that wasn't supposed
to win tsm saw a chance to learn from
defeat and where others saw a team
destined to lose tsm saw a chance to win
it all this could be an easy pick for
him flashes go in but they sail over his
head he's immune to all of them read so
well by bolo and he's got two little
from with the diffuser down a third but
no dan walks away from that challa picks
up two big kills it's all up to chala
but dan can't get it we're going to
overtime again oh my god these teams
i hope that you don't have anything in
your hands because i'm throwing them up
in the air if it's up to me
[Music]
all right folks before we get into the
video i just want to remind you all to
please sub to the channel and turn on
notifications if you haven't done it yet
because it really does help we are super
close to 2 million subs and you could be
the person who gets us there and yes i
mean you the person who is watching this
video right now it's gonna be you and i
believe in you okay so tsm siege team is
a rare story in esports esports as a
whole has changed a lot in the last
couple of years teams don't really toil
in obscurity anymore before getting a
big break and then winning it all out of
nowhere and yet that's exactly what
happened to tsm their longest tenured
member achieved spent two years trying
to reach the highest level of
competition through challenger the team
played season 9 of pro league for
accelerate gaming before looking to the
future a new org to sign with and
potential roster changes to make
achieved along with his teammate faults
even got an invitation to try out for
space station gaming's roster during
that time like you know we figured we'd
get an org but you know there's no
guarantee to that there's no guarantee
to what you're gonna get
uh but i ended up going to them for like
a week and then i was like i don't like
this i want to go back to my team part
of the reason for achieved change of
heart was that another opportunity came
up bolo a soon to be 18 year old content
creator with insane mechanics and a
dedicated fan base reached out to the
team with an idea bowling didn't follow
a lot of people on twitter and
everything so he followed like all of us
one night and i was like oh i know what
he wants you know
finding an org to represent everything
is gonna be a lot easier with him you
know because he's a bigger name and
everything and both came in and he's
like listen bro we i can guarantee we
can get this it's fine blah blah blah if
you want to come back i was like yeah bo
joined the team in time for the start of
pro league but despite his incredible
skills a lot of people wondered if his
insane plays on stream would translate
to a real match apparently we were like
the only team like really interested in
i guess because a lot of people were you
know very skeptical because
there was a big thing going on that like
bolo is gonna like he's good he has good
aim he's got mechanics but is he gonna
be good like a comp setting and stuff
like that another critical pickup at the
time was merc the all-important ash main
and entry fragger and adding geometrics
into late 2019 brought a wealth of
competitive experience from his time on
evil geniuses as well as a reliable and
knowledgeable support play style when we
first picked him up we just knew that he
he has a bunch of experience and that he
could like help guide us and just mold
the team and that we could learn a lot
of things from him the team exploded
onto the scene as instant fan favorites
they were scrappy underdogs backed up by
insane firepower from one of the most
popular personalities in the game it's
all paulo alone now in the 1v2 to keep
liquid alive as he comes down yellow
stairs there's no chance north american
you have another champion at trina oh no
not like this oh hyper falls two that
was a double from chala a fourth from
achieved it's all down disguise is it on
the flawless round no it's not but it's
a triple for chala that's 23 kills
michael jordan for tsm out here now fan
popularity and domestic success are one
thing but the real mark of competitive
success in siege has always been winning
the six invitational and in that respect
tsm had always come up short in 2020
they finished third behind ninjas in
pajamas and were forced to stand by and
watch as na clinched its second ever sex
invitational win we we're definitely
upset
but
um yeah i mean we're just really happy
like even even though like we didn't get
it we're really happy with like our
performance because that was our that
was our first invitational for four of
us the only one who's ever been to an
invitational before that was geo then
after a rough probing season tsm were
eliminated at si 2021 by team liquid who
went on to take second to net it sucked
but at the same time like we were the
last team standing from every other
region but vladam so it wasn't that bad
like i think we did really well
especially if you consider like stage
before that i think we were all like
just really happy with with that event
because um it kind of showed that like
you know we still got it and everything
and um
you know we obviously we got a lot of
mistakes we got to figure out and stuff
like that but um
like our core fundamentals and stuff are
all still there to win us games after
two years of trying tsm just didn't look
like they had what it took to be the
best team in the world
and it didn't look like si 2022 was
gonna change that brazil's recent
dominance led to even more amazing
brazilian teams there were six at the
tournament then there were team empire
and bds from europe both of whom had the
potential to go deep but besides the
competition dsm had a bigger problem
they had a pretty weak 2021 and when all
was said and done they just barely
missed the cut-off to make it to si tsm
had to play through the regional and a
qualifier to punch their ticket to
stockholm which was enough to make
everyone doubt their ability to perform
at the actual tournament even if they
did make it
but this was a team of grinders they'd
started from the bottom before and the
doubters weren't about to stop them now
tsm half the crossfires this really
doesn't look accomplishable for melton
he has got to get the 4k of his life but
achieved will achieve it from long haul
true to his name dark zero space station
oxygen esports and now tsm are going to
the sixth invitational still even with
their spot in sweden secured there was a
hard road ahead for tsm to some degree
there's a number of unknowns coming into
this competition about them everyone
would have seen how they performed in
the close qualifiers my god did they
make it look pretty easy apart from the
second to last game in which it did come
down to a matter of a few rounds but
then going into the final they
absolutely cleaned out their opponents
we knew that group would be tough um
obviously bds wasn't at their full
potential but uh
you know we knew it would be tough and
uh we just ended up taking it one game
at a time and to make things more
complicated the team made a pretty big
change heading into the tournament not a
roster change but a roll swap now it's
worth talking a little bit about tsm
because they have made some changes
coming into this competition achieved
has moved away from being the go to igel
and murk has taken up that spot what was
interesting for me in the last round as
they said the main reason for that bolo
is more the entry and merck is now the
flex player so what we did was we moved
uh beau to the primary entry role
because you know bo's nasty one of the
best gamers in the game so why not and
so it may just hinder his ability to
deny a plant here merck tries to find
one but pamper manages to cut him down
immediate trade comes in geo's getting
the plant down does somehow tsm have
been able to steal inside a site and may
just steal the round here bow or north
is a challenge to be found and boy does
he find it three on the round for him
going absolutely while taking hyper down
cuts eclipse as well 4k for ball easy
for tsm so now that it murks like
calling
instead of him like
having to tell like yo or like yopo like
play ying and let's try to do this and
do all that he can just say yo i'm gonna
play ying and let's do this you know
what i mean but despite all the hype
things didn't get off to a great start
tsm squeaked into the upper bracket
after a third place finish in their
group and no one really expected much
from them after that
but despite their shaky initial
performance
tsm went on a rampage
it's four versus two it's all fallen
apart in the last second moosie gets one
back but he's gonna go absolutely huge
geo with the shutdown tsm stop nip in
round 12. he's not moving anywhere he's
going to keep himself put sure
he knows now surely he goes to the free
fire does he get it
comes out on top
come out on top three versus two with
geo try and sit the diffuser nest coming
in towards bleepers big c4 over the top
but it gets shots out resets is down
nesk has got to do it all bolo steps up
for the challenge it's a little bit of a
1v1 the close angle the polo wins and
sends them further into the upper
bracket liquid drop down to the lower
tsm's run through the upper bracket at
si 2022 wasn't just a massacre it was
personal on their way to the upper
bracket finals tsm beat the two
brazilian teams that eliminated them
from the last two sis it looked like the
party was gonna stop there though tsm
took a close loss to team empire who
were easily among the tournament
favorites and it's a four versus two
going for tsm into the post plan geo's
out in the open but now down on the
ground here achieved with a position in
cool vibes though catches one of the
members of empire he's got so much to
contend against though a direct fight at
the top of cool vibes is waiting for him
here he spotted the player in the corner
of his eyes but it's not gonna be enough
always shuts it down an empire are your
first grand finalists of the six
invitational 2022
that loss dropped tsm to the lower
bracket where yet another brazilian team
faze clan stood between them and a grand
finals rematch
but faze turned out to be more of a
speed bump than an actual wall holding
up towards dining side and then starts
moving his way down as the round
progresses the problem is his team are
getting hammered on sight here charles
down to half achieve steps up and gets a
big 2k i spoke about that making it a
three
absolutely nuclear from the north side
and lee's souls he's got about 40
seconds to play with as well tim so i
would argue not in a massive rush he can
take a few extra seconds here to get
himself in an ideal position but
achieved his weight in a huge 4k in the
rounds i think somebody has now dropped
the strokes on the blue stairs and
that's going to be a big help but here
come tsm straight into sight there's
merck gets one ball or gets one merc
another achieved surely this is over
five versus one it could be another
flawless round to close it out for tsm
and what a message the north american
side are sending here on chalet cyber
he's looking for anything he can get he
knew there would be nothing charla finds
the shots into the back third flawless
round for tsm and they take map one in
quick fashion it's one versus five the
hall the horps of latam rest on astral's
shoulders right now and he is opening
rotations he's desperately moving he's
trying to do anything he can but there
comes the final kill and it's a flawless
round at the end of a flawless
performance from tsm nothing is going to
prepare you for a team that looks this
good barely dropping around against faze
a team that just three months ago were
the best team in the world
i can't wait for this grand final it is
gonna be a screamer between empire and
tsm tsm dominated faze but the grand
finals weren't just coming up the
matches were all happening on the same
grueling day after we went against faze
i gave everyone a hug and everything but
even like gotcha one of our coaches and
merc were like dude are you gonna smile
like dude we're in the grand finals and
i was just like nah
you know like
it ain't no it ain't over yet like i
want to win this thing like like i'm
happy obviously but like you know i was
just i would just say i was fully
focused honestly like i wasn't really
focused on anything else going into the
grand finals it seemed like empire's
game but tsm were ready they weren't
going to settle for second anymore this
time they had to win what fans got was
one of the most exciting grand finals
ever this is dire straits for the
russian team knowing that the match
could be over or the map could be over
if joystick doesn't pull out ahead he
has a single bit of hp and chalice says
no you don't tsm steal empire's map away
and they take clubhouse the yo-kai can
move into position all they need to do
is get into the right spot shepard is
almost completing it knocked away two
seconds to go oh yes you can stop it
what a good bit of teamwork by tsm but
scyther well what can he get well hold
on a second here we need a temperature
check on this tsm team merck might be
able to get one and there you go
what a performance from mark 14 damn
kills and seven damn rounds tsm take map
number two
they're one map away
from being s i champions seither walks
away with one hp good coverage that's
defuser almost down geo in a 1v3 but
empire they want to send this to map
number four they just need a tiny bit of
geo's hp and they're gonna get it
empire not letting tsm sweep you put
those brooms away ladies and gentlemen
there's an upside down repel mark
doesn't know this always should be able
to get an easy pick and the diffuser
from scyther going down leaves challa to
try and clutch he won't be able to do it
empire refused to die they're on match
point merger falls back off to you
similar story gonna try and kill one
drone each and see what we can do and no
we're gonna run away but geo gets oh it
gets flustered there's too many angles
too many guns doesn't know exactly where
empire was scythe was on the four window
and one gun that's repelled but cypher
finds another and tsm are falling apart
that is one round that i will like 100
remember because like because like we
were we were you know gonna go to bank
if we didn't win that round it was a 5v3
like
you know things weren't looking the best
in the middle of the round the hibana
popping up the polo looks the wrong way
this could be an easy pick for him
flashes go in but they sail over his
head he's immune to all of them read so
well by bolo and he's got too long from
with the defuser down a third but no dan
walks away from that challa picks up two
big kills it's all up t'challa but dan
can't get it we're going to overtime
again oh my god these teams
still it's a 4v4 empire empire plenty of
time to work with but they have to
tackle these shields bolo in his
position will creep up there's still an
upside down repel scyther has an abuser
it's a double kill from achieved what
are we witnessing always upside down and
he's gonna bait it out because nothing
will happen
tsm
move to championship point
it's a 5v1 if there's ever been the time
for a flawless round
it's now
everything on the line for tsm what a
year it's been from them
and it's all now shepherd to try and
stop it empire have come so close before
but they've fallen short and they'll do
so again tsm said trust the process the
process just won you
a world championship
tsm are your six invitational 2022
world champs
they come through the open qualifier
they had no chance at making here
besides that last option and against all
lots as one of the lowest seeds at this
entire event
they've done it
as tsm lifted the hammer and claimed
their first sixth invitational win it
was more than just an individual victory
for their captain or their superstar it
was a testament to the fact that where
you start off doesn't define where you
end up
challenger qualifiers even content
creation none of it matters and while
other teams shuffled trying to find that
winning combination tsm simply decided
to double down on playing their hand
differently you know if they don't have
a good event or whatever they end up
like dropping some people and making
roster moves and stuff so the fact that
like we didn't do that
um
and we just kind of stuck with like our
core team and and just did it the way we
wanted to is is really special the
payoff wasn't just a championship it
wasn't just an mvp award for achieved
either the man who grinded with this
moment in mind for years it was the
opportunity to look around the team as
they lifted the hammer to know the
struggles they faced and more than
anything else to understand how those
players grew to overcome them all
i think it goes to show that even if you
have a bad event or two like you know
you can bounce back and regain that
motivation and play well again and stuff
like that so i think that that was
really special for us
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our twitter
instagram facebook and tick tock